okay before this video starts I have a
very very very very very very important
announcement
isn't that right cringe miss is coming
on Friday and Saturday so cancel all
your planes because you don't want to
mince cringe miss it's a livestream mark
and Jack are flying all over here to
Brighton we got this whole thing set up
it's gonna be the best livestream ever
and it's for charity it's for the
charity red which we're also supporting
with trooper simulator it's to help
prevent AIDS it's a great charity we got
a lot of cool stuff happening on the
livestream a lot of people are coming a
lot of people involved and there's a
penguin we have a penguin do I need to
tell anything else I don't think so but
PJ and Emma is coming to they live in
Brighton so obviously they're gonna be
there there's gonna be presents all
kinds of [ __ ] Friday 5 p.m.
I'll see you that UK time all the info
is in the description and you don't want
to miss this one I've done a lot of
livestream but this is by far the
biggest one I've ever done so no I'm not
a Nazi I'm not I promise it's just a
stupid article
[Music]
hail Hydra I'm used to getting hate
comments and just generally really dumb
comments that's normal but now we got
some next-level [ __ ] this is this is
kind of impressing you know I've seen
bad articles but now they all just came
out of once YouTube removing PewDiePie
subscribers after news comes through
that he is in favor of the Nazi Party
okay no that one is clearly fake okay
fake article what else do we got
PewDiePie says YouTube is killing his
channel because he's white okay clearly
another fake
Oh PewDiePie more like pewdie wine got
roasted that's just too clever how can I
possibly have a response pewdie wine how
come I never thought about that before
it's genius
is there anything more annoying than
some insecure rich guy with insecure
[Music]
okay again I guess you know I mean I
know I'm I'm in love self-conscious
about my body I feel I feel weird about
it but you didn't have to sneak that in
there okay
what do you mean insecure [ __ ] what do
you mean is there anything more annoying
yes it is this article how about that
for starter that their victim of a
conspiracy against them for being white
what what why do they why do they get
this front to kill my it really seems
like he's really serious right there I
really didn't detect any sarcasm in his
language so I'm gonna go ahead in there
write an article where I slander him
pretty much that seems like the right
thing to do and and while I'm at it I'm
gonna sneak him and call him insecure
hmm what's the title PewDiePie pewdie
[ __ ] no that's not good enough I got it
beauty wine because he complaints
roasted okay here's the thing can you
tell when I'm speaking seriously and
like I said this is not just affecting
me it's affecting other youtubers and
creators that you care about like does
this guy have autism I don't like to
make that joke but I'm I'm I'm concerned
if he thinks that was if he can't tell
the difference like why is this an
article because clickbait maybe that's
why because because hating on PewDiePie
is such a meme that we can we can get
more clicks from it good you did you did
a good job
Congrats hey man Congrats on your
journalism job I thought you're really
doing a great job this apparent
conspiracy against him has led to his
popularity failing he said in a video
where he ranted against the video
hosting site but it's this part of the
clip that's even more ridiculous than
the rest of it they want someone else on
top someone really extremely cancerous
like Lilly sinks I'm white
can I make that comment but I do think
that's a problem no I dad you know what
that seemed that seemed like something
he was serious about he really seemed
genuine about that statement so no I'm
glad you created this so here we go
sweetie juice where was the most
subscribed user on the site highest
earner with an annual income of 12
million it's also funny because
apparently he just wrote $12 but then
updated it so I'm curious what else he
corrected in this article oh oh I can
taste the salt through the article oh oh
it's nice and salty oh and by the way 12
million oh that's cute he thinks I'll
make 12 million okay sure what what have
you want buddy whatever you say man also
claim that YouTube wanted to put someone
else on top of the site someone
extremely handsome rests well I'm gonna
change that into you James Dawson you're
extremely cancerous
the new top dog might be Lilly Singh a
Canadian with Indian heritage he
suggested no I never said that
what the [ __ ] I'm the top dog wish I was
Canadian it's [ __ ] [ __ ] nice one
get cracking than me that's journalism
right there ending an article with get
cracking then mate I didn't know British
media was just so bad it's so bad you
know I thought Swedish media was
babbitt's in British media it's just
this this is the weirdest thing I've
ever seen this is what people would
actually think if I didn't have a chance
student you know because people just
read the title people just read this and
they're like oh okay
I see pretty Pais and not see now that's
all right it's extremely annoying how I
can't make jokes on my channel without
anyone quoting it as actual facts like
something I actually said do they know
my have they seen any videos coming out
of my channel are they so desperate for
clickbait that they were literally
literally slander someone else's name in
the process you know they're clearly
taking my name shoving it into the
ground just to get more clicks on their
shitty [ __ ] website it's it's
disgusting it's absolutely disgusting
how desperate can you be this clickbait
journalism it's just the purest form of
cancer sport rages what the [ __ ] is that
why sport rages posting that I'm that
I'm racist
Peter pie racist questioning work what
the [ __ ] is this how is this a thing how
he was being sarcastic to even watch the
video fool
thank you well I'm glad to see that
people understand in the comments
good god when did you become BuzzFeed
remember when you were an actual
newspaper for real journalists well this
is just how it is now because [ __ ]
BuzzFeed gets millions of click in real
real news stories doesn't get enough
coverage so you they got a clickbait to
keep up you know you know if keemstar
has more journalistic integrity than you
then you know it's a big it's a big
[ __ ] problem and by the way Peter pie
isn't white
he is Sweden okay so can I make that
comment can I say that you crying about
not getting 2 mil very I am lucky to get
two hundred various own abuse and I have
been on YouTube since 2008 stops ooking
grow up
you know what I won't stop sucking shut
the [ __ ] up I'll sook as much as I like
okay you don't know me I've been sucking
since 2008 this is so typical
alright this one wasn't directed at me
but whatever I found it PewDiePie is
literally complaining that one of his
videos didn't reach two million views
well I'm laughing my [ __ ] ass off cry
about that did you watch there's anyone
watch the whole video it's always just
picking whatever part that they said you
know think it's convenient the video
literally is me standing up for everyone
on YouTube and I even explained that
it's not about the views it's about
reaching your audience but you know
whatever is convenient for you to [ __ ]
on me go ahead you know some of his
videos only get 2 million views it's
hardly worth his pulling a t-shirt on
talking for 6 minutes in a totally
adorable super relatable way about
putting the t-shirt on then asking his
subscribers to leave feedback about the
t-shirt while meanwhile checking a
Forbes is putting him on the 2006
Richard stars list this is the saltiest
[ __ ] I have ever read you know what I
didn't I didn't ask for my private
banking to get leaked ok I didn't I
don't care take away [ __ ] 3 zeroes on
my paycheck I would you know what make
it 4 take away 4 zeros on my paycheck I
would still be making this they never
seem to end for some reason they always
you know every year there's something
coming out like this or just insane
claims about me you know I've read
articles about me all about all kinds of
[ __ ] I'm I'm racist now then I'm sexist
I think that I there's been like I've
been a pedophile it's just so many
insane claims oh that I was hitting my
girlfriend it's like these like horrific
claims
I just keep have to take from me from
the media it will get them clicks and
who cares who cares if there's a real
person behind it right I mean media has
been doing this for years literally
slandering people so what's the [ __ ]
difference now hmm who cares about
YouTube oh I don't like you to oh gotta
write an article
oh he's racist now uh I don't like that
he's making more money than me oh it's
not fair
getting in the media's public attention
if anything I realized is that whatever
I've learned about other people through
media it's clearly being skewed while it
while growing up and because I've seen
how they represent me in the media and
you know what it's fine if I'm if I'm
not perfectly represented in the media
but when there's just pure [ __ ]
slander like this I'm not gonna just
stand it like step aside for her and
take it this is this is it's too it's
too dumb thanks for defending me when
these shitty stupid articles arrive I
really appreciate that and I'll see you
in the next video stay awesome
[Music]
[Applause]